hello and welcome to the Evan Carmichael
show I believe in entrepreneurs and this
show is all about helping you become
more successful how can you realize your
business goals and you may be at the
point where you feel like you're not
getting the momentum you need we're just
things aren't where your sake we're
going to be where you feel like your
time is worth more than what you're
getting out of it you put in a lot of
time a lot of effort a lot of dollars
and you just not seen the results that
you thought you were going to see that's
what this show is all about and I'm
looking forward to helping you now
today's episode is really important I
mean you know all the episodes are
important but today's episode is
extremely important because I'm going to
be sharing with you the fastest way to
grow your business and I've used this
strategy multiple times and it literally
saved my first business and have a huge
impact on my life and so today I'm going
to be sharing that with you so what's
the strategy the fastest way to grow
your business is through alliances this
is so important a lot of entrepreneurs
is how they start out they start a
business they have a product of server
that they poured their energy and
passion into and you go out and you try
to get one customer at a time like one
customer and another customer into
another customer and another customer
and it's so slow it's such a momentum
suck it takes you so long to get to
where you need to be because you're
closing one customer at a time and the
past can still work it just takes so
long to get to where you want to be and
a lot of times entrence will give up
along the way because you just not
getting the momentum you need the better
way to do it the faster way to do it is
to work with alliance partners so what
do I mean by this what you want to do is
find people who are already selling to
your target market and find a way to
work together these are not your direct
competitors okay you're not going to go
to your direct competition and say hey
you want to look together I'm talking
people who are selling other products
and services to your target customer
and working with them on some kind of
arrangement there's a million ways to
skin the cat will give into it later in
the show but working with them to help
introduce your product and service to
their clients that's the fastest way to
grow because now instead of warning one
customer at a time one customer at a
time one customer at time when you close
an alliance partner they may have
hundreds or thousands or tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
your customers already and if you close
just a handful of those alliance
partners they'll do all the work you
need to grow your business because they
already have the voice right they have
the customers who are listening to them
and when they say hey you need to go
check this out people are going to do it
so encouraging you today to look at who
you can partner with form alliances with
to help spread your message now we're
going to get into some specific
strategies and examples later in the
show but I wanted to start with a story
this is a personal story of how this
strategy really impacted my business in
my life in my first business it was a
software company whose biotechnology
software and you know science is my
worst subject in school eyes drop that
as soon as I could I had no computer
background and I'm sure my high school
science teachers would be laughing at me
thinking what you are running a
biotechnology software company that's
got to be some kind of joke anyway so I
was struggling yeah I had this business
I started it up I had two partners and
we were struggling and we weren't making
a lot of money and and it sucked because
up until that point everything I had
done I had been great at you know I'd
always excelled and here I was trying to
run this business and I wasn't I wasn't
doing well I was making three hundred
dollars a month three hundred dollars a
month you know if you can't survive on
that was eating beans for lunch every
day and it took its toll and and I just
pounded on my sense of self-worth and I
felt like a total failure I felt like
this wasn't working out and I didn't
know what I what I would do and I
remember one day I called my business
partner up and I told me
you know what I quit this is just too
much we're not getting where we want to
go I'm so frustrated I feel like a total
loser I gotta go do something valuable
with my time I quit and just hearing
those words come out of my mouth was a
shock because I'm not a quitter and I
hung up the phone and I cried I bawled
my eyes out for 20 minutes I'm the next
day I woke up and and went back to work
I went back to the company and it was
just too important to quit on you know
what we were doing was too important and
I didn't want to have this disdain on my
resume you know saying that I quit on
this because I didn't want to quit once
and always have that be a part of me
have to figure out a way to do it and
the light bulb moment went off for me
when I realized you know what I'm not
the first guy to trying to sell software
before I'm not the first kind of try to
do this and even though I don't have any
background in science they have no
background in software now I'm trying to
run the scientific software company I'm
not the first got to try to do this let
me model success let me find someone who
has done it and apply that strategy to
help me grow my business you know what I
had nothing else to lose those already a
rock bottom has nothing else to lose and
there was no big player in my industry
biotech software so i expanded the scope
and looked at software in general and
looked at okay who's a big software
company and it looked at Microsoft
Microsoft was the number one company in
software at the time I said you know
what how do they get started how to deal
gates start this thing up and I don't
care help Bill Gates mixing action
million dollars now but 021 how did he
make that first million that's what I
want to do that's what I want to learn
and I looked at their story and I dug
back into their archives and i found
that microsoft made their money through
alliances they consistently found
alliance partners to help them grow
their business when they launched their
software they warned as they are trying
to sell one piece of software at a time
to one customer at a time but what is
taking way too long what they did was
try to find people who are already
selling other things to the customers
that they wanted to reach so they have a
defined
more time these are the types of people
who want to reach out to and they
thought who else is selling to these
guys let's find a way to make a
partnership and Microsoft's big deal
came with IBM an IBM agreed to sell all
of their computers with Microsoft
software on it and with a huge deal you
know computers need software and they
chose Microsoft and Mike IBM was the
biggest computer maker at the time and
now every single I've been computer that
was shipped time Microsoft software
honor by Microsoft making that one
partnership arrangement that one
alliance agreement be able to explode
their business and they signified
excelling one of the time one of the
time one of the times let's attack these
channel partners and the funny thing is
looking back at their story that was the
deal that make them that was the deal
that made Microsoft huge that exploded
the business up but they were a 7
million dollar company when they
approached that vm for that deal now
several million dollars not a huge
company but it's still a seven million
dollars health me I would like I would
have liked it via 7 million dollar
company was having these problems i'm
making three hundred dollars a month
show me how to get the 7 million i take
that any day of the year and so i look
back to see well how did they get the 7
million and then again was through
alliance partnerships they continued to
find people who are selling to their
target audience and partner up with them
and some of the deals worked out and
some of them didn't but that was their
focus and that's how they became a
million-dollar company a seven million
dollar company the billion dollar
company and beyond it's such a science
way to grow your business a Microsoft
came out of nowhere if you look at how
long it takes companies to get started
and to grow on to build a client base a
lot of the biggest companies in the
world took years and years and years and
years and Microsoft came out of nowhere
to explode onto the scene with their
software because they formed alliance
partners so if you have something really
good are you I'm assuming you have a
great product a great service you're
ready to go you're ready to hit the
market you know you're not in testing
phase anymores like I
customers now show me some momentum I am
ready hit me up instead of trying to
sell one at a time one of the time one
at a time look at who else your
customers are buying from and make a
list makes a list of everybody that your
customers could potentially buy from
before they buy from you after they buy
from you and reach out to those people
because those people are going to be
great with entertainers to talk to you
and it's so much easier a sale call to
call up somebody here one explore if
there's a way we can make a partnership
together then any will you buy my stuff
makes a big difference it's a lot easier
call to make it's a lot easier sale to
make and it can have a lot bigger impact
on the growth of your business instead
of trying to sell one at a time so this
whole show is dedicated to showing you
how to make those alliance partners
happen welcome back to the island
Carmichael show I believe in
entrepreneurs and this show it's all
about helping you reach your business
goals as an entrepreneur today I'm
talking about forming alliances and it
being the fastest way to grow your
business is instead of selling one one
one one customer at a time you work with
alliance partners who can reach that
audience for you and spread your message
for you so I was talking about Microsoft
now to talk about how I was at my wit's
end I almost gave up my business i was
making 300 bucks a month and i didn't
know what to do and i thought of
quitting i told my partner I quit and I
thought you know what I'm not the first
kind of try to sell software before and
I copied their strategies and I said you
know why I got nothing else to lose so
let's give this a shot and I started
reaching out so my customers were going
to be scientists researchers it's not
okay you know what I'm going to make a
list of all the different researchers
that I know and think about who else
they buy from other types of companies
that they buy from and i would start
reaching out to them and that's what i
did i reached out to them one by one
those alliance partners and within a
couple weeks i had my first deal and it
was for 13 and a half thousand dollars
13 and a half thousand dollars you know
that may not sound like a lot of money
to you guys listen right now but to me
man I hit the jackpot because i was
making 300 bucks a month 13 and a half
thousand dollars are you kidding me I
was so happy when that check came in I
couldn't believe my eyes more important
than having the 13 and a half K was I
had a system now like I finally found
something that worked after trying all
this stuff that didn't I finally had
something that worked and I could
replicate and do again and again and
again and so I started closing more
partnerships and more deal and look for
more alliance partners and that was my
main role that's why they ended up doing
and so I want you guys to go and look
for partners I want to get to the call I
have Robin on the line Robin where are
you from and how can I help good morning
I'm from California Bakersfield
California around thank you well I'm
calling today because i have a blog it's
called the curvy momager and as a result
of that blog growing i have created a
product line of t-shirts and a few other
items and have started to do event and
so I'm thinking to myself it's time to
register myself as a company and get
some of those things in place and I just
have no idea what to do okay is it just
you in the business it's just me cool so
there's a couple ways to do it right now
you're set up probably as a sole
proprietorship and hold it the risk is
under your name right the bank account
is you know you it's your bank account
and the biggest risk is if somebody
Sue's you you you were on the hook for
everything they could take your house
your car everything now you're in a blog
so you may not get sued as easily as
other companies would but the last way
to do it is to set up a corporation so
long cetaphil corporation and you call
it whatever whatever name you want maybe
off your blog name
in it protects you it can protect your
your company name right so nobody else
can take that company name I mean if
anybody sees you then the worst case
scenario is they could only take within
the company's bank account not within
your personal bank account yeah like if
I had me met such a trip spoke ankle
base numbers gotcha exactly and you can
get insurance for your company as well
so that if somebody does break an ankle
or whatever an event then then your
insurance would help covered as well and
they don't think rep your company
definitely we're with you all gap so I
mean I'm part of a salsa dancing company
here I've invest in the salsa dance
company in toronto and that was one of
the first things like okay we got to get
incorporated and we have to get
insurance because somebody comes to one
of our dance events and they hurt
themselves or they slip on the floor and
water or whatever you want to be I don't
want to lose my house in my car because
of that exactly exactly and each other
things you don't think about when you
are starting a bispecific yeah and it
also helps with your your numbers so
that it's important to keep your
personal thank you can't separate from
your business bank account and it helps
you when you're you know filing your
taxes and you you can pay a lot less
taxes as a corporation then as an
individual so there's a lot of tax
planning you know you may not be making
too much money yet but as those dollars
come in you know tax plan is going to be
super important and so shows the money
is your company and your invest in it
then the money you make as a corporation
is tapped much more favorably than the
other person's along the ledge all right
okay thank you so much for the advice I
have a little bit more direction of what
about cool do you see this as being
always yourself in the business or are
you going to bring on partners um well
the interesting pieces I've had people
contact me about partnering with them on
different things so we may be adding
some additional people okay
you can form alliances which is what
we're talking about now where they have
their own company you have your own
company and you're trying to find ways
to help each other out I may be here in
the Commission back and forth or air is
more you have somebody who owns a piece
of your companies I like the ASP better
I was a good way to do it is a good way
to do it means but some people you know
if you like if you're going to grow
you're going to need investors you want
to sell shares in your business if
you're ever going to bring on a partner
you have to get incorporated what's
going to happen is when you get
incorporated you get issued a number of
shares and so right now you're going to
own all the shares you're a hundred
percent shareholder but if you ever do
want to give some equity to somebody
maybe it's a really important employee
that you bring on or investor in the
business then you can sell them some of
your shares or maybe in one day sell all
your shares if you want to you know get
acquired somebody says hey Robin you
know what here's ten million dollars to
your blog business well I thinking to
leave it right you got it so you can
easily tell those tears off to some
people okay boy yeah that's all right
good luck Robin thanks for calling in
thanks so much you enjoy the rest of the
show all right yeah and if everybody
listening it's super important to get
incorporated I mean it's okay to test
out at the stars test us to see if you
you know like this business if you're
going to keep going with it if it's
something that has some traction but
there's a big risk of somebody suing you
and taking everything from you and so
the way to prevent that is to get
incorporated launch a business properly
how much your whole disagreement you'll
have all the chairs that you own
yourself in teach everyone cell and go
look at getting some kind of insurance
policy out it's something that you know
not a lot of entrepreneurs think about
at the start because it's so focused on
getting getting customers giving our
business off the ground when you got to
protect yourself right you want to
protect your business name you want to
protect your personal bank account and
you want to be able to make sure that
you're you know still around and
years and being incorporated is a great
way to go so go check it out doesn't
cost a lot and Destin worthwhile for
everybody launching the business today
I'm talking about forming alliances and
it's been the fastest way to grow your
company find people who are already
selling to your target audience and find
a way to work together I talked about
Microsoft and how they formed alliances
to grow I talked about my business and
how it went from three hundred dollars a
month to close to my first deal at
thirteen and a half thousand and then
having a strategy I could use to grow
from there and I close partnership after
partnership the partnership and in a
couple years we do so quickly that we
had customers in 30 countries I has a
NASA I had johnson johnson as customers
and my company got acquired and that was
from from nothing from three hundred
dollars a month have been acquired and
having that massive growth in three
years that's what happens when you form
solid alliances now I talked about
Microsoft and how they use that deal to
help them grow they still did it later
on even as they grew as they were big
companies when they entered into new
deals into new markets they always try
to look at who they get through it so
here's an example microsoft owns expedia
the popular travel website and when they
won went into it they realize he you
know what we don't know anything about
travel we define something to help us
get into this space until department
with american express an American
Express had a long track record with
their credit cards and the traveler's
checks in the travel world and so they
went into it together and after a couple
years deal with amex would drop out and
Microsoft would own the whole thing and
they use that partnership to understand
the business to get leverage to get
traction and then grow an expedia is
massively popular right now so they
still use it to this day this isn't just
a strategy to start off this is one you
can use on going to continue building
your business what you want to do now is
think about you being one of many people
that your customers buy from and you
want to think about ideally who are your
customers buying from before they buy
from you so as an example is talking
about with robin and our last caller
about the salsa company that i'm
involved with here in Toronto who is
audience typically as people who are
moving into the neighborhood those are
the best people who will then look for
something new to do and want us how to
take about the class so hopefully
partner with think about who are those
people buying from and working with
before they move into this into the area
right so maybe they're working with real
estate agents because they're working
with home inspectors either working with
insurance daughters rate these are all
people who you have to look and work
with before we move into a neighborhood
and so what i would do is partner up
with the local real estate agents local
home inspectors local insurance brokers
and find ways to work together maybe
thinking about these guys they don't
care about the salsa why would they be
promoting me and how can I tell them the
point is you've given them an
opportunity to show some love to their
customers all right you're giving them
an opportunity to say hey welcome to the
neighborhood here's a great service that
you might want to go check out if you're
looking to make some friends right and
as those agents develop relationships
with their clients and they know their
needs and they know what they're worried
about ourselves the company could be a
good solution for that you can get lots
of referral so that way so you ideally
want to look at who your customers are
buying from before they buy from you and
reach out to them to form alliances and
a lot of different ways of skin that cat
but that's how you want to do it so
here's an example I'm trying to tell the
entrepreneurs this may be more for you
guys understand because you're
entrepreneurs so i'm trying to sell to
you how would I form alliances to try to
sell one ounce for the time will take
too much time so I might talk to
insurance brokers or financial advisers
or bankers or accountants or lawyers or
web designers or PR agents or management
consultants or staffing companies these
are all people that we work with as
entrepreneurs and you work with a lawyer
and you've worked with them for years
and you love them and you respect them
and they know you have a suitable
problem and they say hey here's the
solution you're going to check it out
she got to find those alliances so the
dick expect to work for you o mighty to
the call I have Tiffany on the line
Tiffany where are you from and how can I
hi I'm from San Francisco California
that's in fact about California all
right welcome babe so I just launched my
first business i'm at the product it's
actually a scarf with a built-in neck
pillow so speaking of travel and we
launched on our website and we prescribe
calm and we want to know you know we
have a lot of success online we're
looking also at selling you know ebay
and amazon all be online outlet when is
the correct time in the startup to
consider retail we don't want to muddy
the waters we want to make sure our
customers you have a seamless you know
supply chain and transition delivery so
we want to know when do we consider
going to retail are you guys profitable
yet i'm at this point our goal for the
first year is to break even of course if
we believe in in business for the part
for three months now I've always seen
you know several hits to our website and
a lot of success with all of our goals
in the first few months right okay so
the thing with going for retail and it
depends on how big an order you get so
typically when a new company comes out
you start with mom and pop shops and
they're they're not ordering huge
quantities right you're not telling the
costco here you're selling to you know
maybelline's fashion accessories and so
maybe they're only at buying 10 from you
okay the challenge is when you go for a
big deal if you're trying to get into
you know i don't know what the price
point is of your product or whatever
like the big retailer is walmart or
costco or Nordstrom or whatever you're
trying to get when they make an order
they might be buying like in the tens of
thousands and so how are you going to
produce that mmm right if you're not
possible yet you don't have steady cash
coming in then you're going to have to
go and get money so it could be from a
bank you could become an investor to
finance that and if it doesn't sell
they're going to ship it back to you and
you have to return the money so you can
actually holding a lot of product that
you're you thought you would sell but
they're shipping back so it's a risk and
it's really one you want to take that
risk some entrepreneurs to take it right
away and it works out and others they
take you right away that doesn't work
it's just a calculated risk so I mean if
you if you have a more you know played
safe mindset it would start online have
success there build a following
circulating the movement around it
online and you could do with this will
show media stops and create campaign and
start with your local area and show that
it's working maybe even start if you can
get on the shopping channel or QVC to
promote it that way but then to go and
make the bigger retail orders what's
your appetite for risk because if they
say okay we want 25,000 of these
superstars then how you're going to fund
that and what happens if they don't sell
so essentially there's no particular
business metrics that you look at you
know financially in the start of day
okay never ready to go a retail not
ready to take that risk is it when you
become profitable or that when you get
the funding so have you been funded so
far that your own your own money or you
have yep we've funded are funded the
business through state personal savings
and then through an SBA loan okay so you
know if you had to find 50,000 units to
make it how would you do it we have an
approved for a line of credit but of
course you know that we don't want we
don't want to necessarily use all of our
line credit for inventory at this time
when we could be using it for marketing
and product awareness so that's kind of
a catch-22 is if we don't want to we do
have money but we don't want to put onto
inventory so I guess that should tell me
that if we don't have money to market
the product then it's not time correct
and we don't want to get away a piece of
the business you don't want that you'll
get an investor this time so I guess our
decision has been it's not time so just
wait well the difference is you know you
don't want to just order this product
without and be sitting on different or
without a sale but it's saloon if I
nordstrom comes with hey we want 50,000
units you're you're now producing to
fill up sale it's a big difference and
do that then then you can do with the
risk is like now you go out of work hard
to make sure all of those things salad
nordstrom right like you're pumping or
tumors you're putting stuff out on
social media and YouTube campaign
go to nordstrom buy our stuff because
you don't want those things to be
returned to you right right so if you if
you have if you have the line of credit
back came to be able to go and do this
then it's still your appetite for risk
right if you're if you're safer than you
may say okay I'm going to wait till I
have some cash flow coming in and I
impossible because a bank isn't really
going to look at your business until you
have profits and have been around for
three years it's typically what they
want to be so it's your it's your
judgment call but I would say if you
have the money and you get a big order
then then go for it and work your butts
off to make sure that those products are
selling at nordstrom whatever they want
from you you're there como ting and
driving people into their stores that's
perfect awesome thank you so much I
really appreciate it no problem any
sleeper scarce calm that was that yep
yes it is thank you okay sounds
interesting i'm gonna i'm going to check
it out yeah definitely you'll love it
yeah and for everybody called everyone
in this room in it is a tough call like
at what point you take the risk and
there's no solid answer just depends on
your appetite for risk is are you
willing to bet the company right now or
do you want to go for slower growth and
it has to be a personal decision that
you're not going to look back on and say
you know I really rich wish I did it you
know do you have that regret or not so
good luck today we're talking about
alliances and I wanted to give you some
specifics so great Evan you know I found
who i want to talk to how do i structure
deal with them and there's a lot of
different ways to do it first one to
think about it do they want to get paid
or not so if you're talking to someone
who's the potential through a lot of
customers are they interested in it
because of the money which is because
they're going to offer value to their
clients and some people will do it just
because they love what you do and they
want to provide value add to their
service remember quite make it a good
referral to somebody and makes them look
good too but some people want to do it
for the money so you have to figure that
out and you have a coffee with them and
talk about it if you're going to do a
commission is it a lifetime commission
or just a first-time commission right
hopefully you know what is the lifetime
value of your customer right you want
some buying more than just one of things
from you one time right so what's the
lifetime value
customer in a common method is to give
up the commission off of the first sale
all the profits are going to make up
that per sale give them away you give
them a margin to motivate right you want
to give them a margin that's good enough
to motivate them to talk about you and
then you make all your sales off to the
back end by selling more products more
services to them you want to think about
what is the value out to their clients
rights if i'm selling salsa services
salsa classes and a real estate agent is
going to refer my business why would you
do that well because it's giving the
person is new to the area doesn't know
anything about this community is moving
in some of these funded they can go do
and new friends they can meet right if
it's a meal 90 year old couple maybe
they won't be coming to salsa classes
but it was a young single woman just
moving in from Vancouver and doesn't
know anybody in the city then that's a
good potential fit and so you're
providing great value to her by telling
her about the classes and then last is
thinking about how you can over deliver
for that it's a common theme i have in
my show how to over-deliver like crazy
so what else can you do to help your
alliance partners as well all right so
can you put them up on your website and
showcase their services or interview
them for your blog or put them on your
social media or follow them on Twitter
and and engage with them think of how
else you can help their business beyond
just sharing this one client that you
work together on I have Marcus on the
line markets where are you from how can
I help hey I'm so long hey Bill North
Carolina all right welcome to the
program what's going on nothing much i'm
monitoring be um iono here so on I
heaven a exotic hair Odyssey hair show
coming up and I'm i do want to you know
promote my beta that promote the show
but i'm wondering like for my business
aspect of fostering the show how can i
go about getting like big-time sponsors
like for the hairs on like crown or our
gods are you know big big hair industry
people to sponsor the air show okay so
what's so different about this hair show
this hair show isn't just like Clayton
collection this is like a fantasy hair
show we have like spending pieces off
the hand we have lighting pieces we have
it's just not your typical hair so it's
a fantasy action so it's not just a sit
down and look at someone cut hair this
is an actual production okay and who
else is involved in this um it's Rick
basically my salon it's Marcus dull
salon we're based on a favor of
kilometers is our eighth annual exotic
hair Odyssey and we would just start to
reach out to other people to get
involved um you know in the hair show
because we've been noted for eight years
so now it's kind of get like a little
bigger than us we're trying to see if we
get some big sponsors you know cool well
I'm excited for you so here's the thing
okay what companies are looking to
sponsor right they have full-time
employees at their business whose job it
is to decide who are we going to sponsor
this year and you have to make the case
now why should be you instead of
somebody else and the two things that
you want to show is one how is this
thing really different so if you're
doing really innovative stuff with hair
that's never been done before then the
partners that you want to partner up
with our people who value innovation
right the companies who love different
and who want to be associated with a
different innovative type of show so you
can look at the brand and see well who
cares about innovation and who does it
so that's one mark already second
they're going to look at the reach so
you've been doing this for eight years
that's great you can say okay here's our
growth here's how many people coming out
but what I would do is topic of the show
is form alliances I would love God who
else you can partner with to 10 times
the size of the show who are not
competitors to you not here so on people
but other people who offer complimentary
services who can bring their audience
out so you have your leg 11 right so if
you're approaching me if I'm the right
partner say I'm full
really care about innovation and I
really care about what you're doing this
is great I'm looking at okay how many
people is this thing going to reach and
you've done you know you have your
chocolate of eight years but if this
year is now the one where you bringing
on 20 different partners who are all
going to bring in their expertise and
promote to their communities and their
audience and everybody's going to come
together now I'm a lot more interested
as a sponsor to get involved yeah
because we have TV we have commercial
vh1 BTW oh we have TV commercials and we
also have you know internet social media
and radio but it's like I can't find
someone that can sponsor the caliber
that need for them to sponsor too I
don't understand well these guys are
available right but you can you can look
at I would look at jigsaw calm I don't
know if you've heard of jigsaw but check
out jigsaw calm and you can find the
names and titles of people at companies
to call them up you can say whoever is
in charge of sponsorship I forward and
you'll get an email address on the phone
number and you can call them up getting
a liver fake getting the list is uh
isn't super challenging you can also try
to connect people so when you do jigsaw
it will cost you maybe a dollar per name
which isn't you know crazy expensive and
you're talking about big sponsorship
dollars I also look at linkedin and see
if you can connect to specific people
out companies through your own
connections but getting that getting the
list is one thing it's been closing them
on why is it such a big deal and you
know again standing for something
important really showing how different
this is making this a biggest thing ever
bringing on new alliance partners LP
promote this all right that's perfect
and Jake's are lean in yeah good luck
market oh thank you yeah if everybody
calling in I mean I definitely check out
chicks on LinkedIn great ways to reach
out if you know what specific company
trying to reach in a different job title
check out those two websites linkedin
it's free jigsaw again is about a dollar
per lead and a great way to be able to
help you grow your business and get the
people you need to get to
we are at the hour already it's crazy
how quickly time flies I want to thank
my my producers Christie and Josh eyes
on you guys do a great job thank you for
separating Christie Daniela I hope you
feel better we'll see you in two can you
come back into everybody listening
exchange to believe continue to build
your lines partnerships continue to grow
your business and I will be back in two
weeks I look forward to hearing from you
and good luck